welcome to this video playing more gasm
orgasm from from Sweden to orgasm then
the size is this a metal vent or
something it hits it seems like I should
should should know it okay well a six
the chaplain Kozlov let's see of course
that it is serious on the ass you see on
that what is interesting now let's go g3
and interestingness i think i recommend
it be five against that but black has
many possible lines can also take him
take him wow this is that I never saw in
this position interesting okay well
let's let's just develop it turn it
takes some time at least what he's doing
maybe I should have taken Gaia I should
have taken it would have been
interesting
you beautiful okay let's let's get ahead
I think you should dig yeah this looks
like a fairly normal Catalan type of
position ring viale novel gambit damn
bit style 95 probably 97
okay i'm not i'm not sure the this type
of gambit um gambit plate I'm not so
familiar with I hope this is an alien
ig5 queen age five but it's um it's
something I'm absolutely not sure love
another idea of my g5 could be that
after a 45 the night gets a 4 which is
quite a nice square firstly maybe maybe
I did this also FYI five as a as an idea
okay at least is not responding
immediately this is a bit bit reassuring
that it's not completely bonkers okay
activate the Queen ok completely quickly
took it yeah the night is a threatening
piece this is this much is clear but
this this looks like some compensation
at least f4 f5 come on let's not no not
every of course ah God f3 to a more slip
ah no this so sucks I mean okay no I am
yeah why this is really bad i mean it's
it's really important the temple in this
position and f3 is not even a move that
it's it's not a neutral move it's just
completely completely cracked this move
nah
yeah yeah he's offering an exchange but
this doesn't help and I need to play
this anyway even with this loss of time
ok ok I'll f5 yo it's time for drastic
measures rook takes g6 root g 5y why not
why not let's just throw everything at
him it's certainly dangerous and you no
doubt about it wow this looks like
you're very very little moons in this
position to be honest in the synthesis
quite threatening ok Queen h7 is not on
but it's close hmm
just mmm yeah yeah this is very very
tricky and there's various ways to to to
play now and they all look good but
question is what's the best one okay not
sure they all they all look they look
look good yeah I am can take it no no
problem okay Brooke need to keep the
keep the bishop check I'm down long time
this is so as usual the biggest issue
Jim yeah this wasn't the best one very
likely this wasn't the best way to play
count on simply in bad shape here this
at this point of time it's very clear
that why this was completely winning and
I simply failed to find it I really
played played badly i mean he he what he
did is just cannot do that losing all
this time and have no defensive
defensive piece it was some it was
probably just a complete winning with
good play okay I can still try to to to
be a bit to annoy him a bit but how well
Rock g5 rook g7 it's still not so easy
probably why should we watch Lewis of
course but it's not so easy how does he
defend that
yeah well this shows that properly white
at very good position at some point even
after blundering lots of stuff it's it's
chats a bit tricky here isn't this just
isn't winning at least I can't take
intake ever take him if it takes and I
take on h7 I'm threatening made you can
go I can you create that's King time
morning groups Isom that's jaquette and
no it's not segment I come on hey and I
really need to break him I really need a
rig of what white resign I mean instead
of this nonsense I course could have
taken a 5 + f7 which is at least a draw
come on oh man I need to break I need to
break bad name I really thought okay
we'll get seven isn't this winning and
check I really thought this is checkmate
forgetting that the bishop is gone and
this is this is just just a draw of
course him the 22 looks secure tab at
your check and we can briefly check how
white could could win the game I'm
pretty sure there were wins if not
there's something this is really it
wouldn't be wouldn't be fair to be
honest at least after Queen d7 okay so
let's check Bishop aged three years
winning okay but it should be four is
not good that surprises me a bit
looks are very very natural to to play
no it's got 93 I the other this is this
is nonsense okay but yeah after this it
can take here champ this is probably not
enough one more like losing okay so
Queen d7 this is the move I need to do i
need to play threatening the rook the
book move with ideas like that
complicated of course yeah i really
thought it would be much easier yeah
well okay the computer find some
interesting stuff here for example
taking Queen takes with a good position
yeah yeah well just a terribly bad game
but okay hope you enjoyed it anyway
thanks for watching